yo today's topic what happened vanilla
shaming vanilla shaming yeah well
there's kick shaming in this vanilla
shaming I don't think people kick it
anymore I think I think they're
vanillishing now yes I don't think King
Shame is even I think it's vanilla
shaming now yes if you tell people
you're not into weird stuff or any
freaky stuff you're like you're so
normal oh you're so boring I'm not gonna
lie that's become a big old pet people
man why because I'm vanilla but there's
more to it that you're hurt
that's not hurt I don't think it is
I think there's a misconception out
there when it comes to what qualifies as
quote unquote good or not good bedroom
fun what makes sexy good for some people
is going to be different for others but
the way a lot of people are introduced
to anything bedroom related or anything
intimacy related is I.E through adult
videos or be through physical responses
to things but when you don't know what
you're doing in the bedroom what do you
do you just do things you're emulating
other people
little King stuff is great like you you
want to bring whips and do all this
other stuff go ham go do your thing but
if you think that's what makes you good
at intercourse you have no idea what the
[__] you're doing
no clue if you can't even do the basics
what is the basic can you even touch
someone well
because best believe a lot of you
[__] have no idea how to touch
someone in a way that makes them feel
physically good some of y'all don't even
know how to kiss people in a way that
feels physically what I mean you only
have your way of kissing you don't know
how to adapt it's almost like dancing
it is you have your way against it but
if a partner is at a basic level or at
advanced level you're gonna do different
things you can't just try to do every
spin you want to do if your follow can't
do that [__] but the way some of y'all
[__] is y'all be using tongue
like it's anybody some women don't like
tongue someone like it you have to even
know how to look at the cues to be this
is [__] basic [__] that no one ever
talks about I know women who are going
to be a thousand times more comfortable
talking to me about their extreme
proclivities and then I ask them like
can you even do the basics well come to
find out they trash they got whips and
dungeons never even learn how to caress
somebody
how are you trying to do backflips you
can't even do a two-step [__] how can
you do a backflip you can't even walk
and you want to tell me you're good at
what you're doing you're good at
movement no it is in it is trendy now to
have a weird kink
oh I I like this or I like this kind of
player this kind of play I'm Different
and they think that makes them
interesting they think that makes them
experts or whatever the [__] it is no it
just means you got a weird proclivity
and that's fine but it doesn't mean
you're actually good at the activity
it's akin to being in a sport like
basketball and thinking you're an expert
because you can do hook shots can you
[__] dribble can you post up can you
cry can you do any other skill just
because you got one particular skill it
doesn't mean you're a well-rounded
player just because you got one
interesting King it don't mean you're
well-rounded when it comes sex in
general it's not because you know how
the dung that you know I don't play
basketball you said something that was
interesting you said a lot of you don't
know your bodies and you don't know your
thing and stuff like that and a lot of
women don't they don't have orgasm and
stuff like that it's funny how the
narrative that is out there is that 73
of women never yes never 17 of women uh
never had an orgasm and I understand
that and the narrative is that they put
the fault on the man
but for a woman
to achieve the O you have to not only
know your body nor your pressure points
but you have to
free your mind
of all the issues and the issues that
you you internally have all the things
that the insecurities that you have if
you got insecurities about yourself and
then you cannot owe if the only thing
you're thinking is that oh my God is my
boom boom clean is do I smell does he
like my thing oh I got stretch marks oh
my God my booty hole is showing if it
you can't you can't you can have a man
doing all all this stuff if your mind
is not there because the reason why we
the reason why we owe and you women
don't
is we're committed you know hold on we
think about that and also it's easier
for us to come and there's less hold on
there's less there's less stigma you
have to understand nothing is entirely
your fault there is less stigma around
you know what I mean so we have to
understand that
but you have to understand what what you
have to do with your oh how much it
involves what's going on in your mind
you being able to achieve that yeah like
it's not just a physical thing it's not
to necessarily put the thing there
wiggle it around and you know you do the
hokey pokey and everything is fine
that's not it what's the man's
responsibility in this
I gotta make you feel good
I gotta make you feel at ease I gotta
read I gotta understand the science I
gotta be able to read what's going on
now I'll be able to ask I have to make
you feel comfortable but I can't achieve
that if you don't even know
yeah I think the issue that someone may
encounter in some situations is that
some dudes don't care I love Myron games
where it's like she goes I don't care
pumping it's not important yeah so
there's dudes who approach it that way
and obviously the the basic problem that
you're having is that you're sleeping
with somebody who doesn't care about you
which is like the first problem you
shouldn't even be sleeping with that
person why would you want to be involved
with somebody who don't care about your
needs boom and if you're fine with doing
that then don't complain about not
having you you you made your bed Lane
boom which is a boring bed apparently
okay
that's your choice but if you're
involved with somebody who does care and
makes effort then you have to do also
part of the labor we have to meet each
other halfway just because the last dude
didn't need you to participate because
he knew all the spots only the next
person is going to do the same you can't
expect the same things from every person
because all the women are different
anyways yes everybody is different
they're all different but certain things
carry over you can pay attention to
certain sensitive spots like the anatomy
of a human being cannot be that
drastically different like I'm gonna
take most women most women are going to
like some ear play of some sorts they
are okay but there's gonna be some that
don't and when you encounter them you
just stop doing it for that person but
it's not like you gotta be like I'm
rediscovering human no no sorry okay oh
that's my spot you and every other on
the planet okay it's not that special
it's not it's not but it's okay you need
to have the experience with each
individual what I'll say is this when we
talk about what people should be able to
do they should be able to do how to find
pleasure
I just wish that we would walk away from
the stuff that's extreme just because
it's easily accessible it's boring to
touch about it to talk about a good
sense of touch it's boring to talk about
you know how to just properly or even
just like
the differences between make a look to
somebody you're intimate with versus
somebody you don't give a [__] about
like and what do those physical
differences like people say [__]
Vegas [__] like oh we were making love
we weren't having like
what does that mean though what does
that mean what does that actually look
like
and people don't talk about that they
just want to talk about the extreme
[__] weird [__]
so I know I just feel that's something
I've noticed before and if you tell
anyone like listen I just like nice
intimate sex with people I like meaning
I like to be able to hold them I like
the whole sense of touch I like being
able to discover
just saying that apparently to a lot of
people that [__] sound boring I'm like
bruv what do you think a regular sex
like supposed to look like you think
it's just chains and whips the whole
time
you want to do some light choking you
want to do something like that rough
sorry choking is not kinky putting a bit
of pressure on the side of the neck like
this that's not that special
you aren't I think people want to own
that because they want to feel special
but you're not
so I don't I just wanted to bring this
up and talk about it because I just
noticed a lot of people get mad about
the whole like vanilla stuff and I'm
like bro it's fine just just do what
you're supposed to do well
anything else you want to say you get
mad about it I don't get mad about it I
just think I I don't get mad about it I
think what bothers me about it is I
think it's just a bad way to have this
discourse because at least a lot of
people having bad sex
so that's what it comes down to because
if the only parameters by which you can
enjoy yourself is you can engage in your
Kink stuff then you are gonna base
yourself on mostly having a bad
intercourse
you're setting yourself up for a bad
time because that stuff you don't just
get it right on the first time oh you
don't you need train you need to learn
it and go through it a few times
get your basics down right you need to
thank yourself yeah and I can't just
have you change up all the time what is
what how about after sex care have you
guys ever talked about that to just lay
in bed and be able to caress the person
what does it feel like do they like
nails on their back do they like their
back gently correct do they like actual
pressure these are things I wish people
talked about why because if you knew the
differences you would actually try it
with your partner be like oh do that
again now you guys can enjoy it even
more [__] don't talk they just
assume they just know how to do it no
time is good to not know and people lie
to each other all the time you know how
many women I heard think they give good
head and that technique is trash listen
if you've ever been with a night walker
you know somebody who works in the
industry y'all listen that technique
ain't the same as you regular ladies
y'all think y'all fire Do Not You
Average at best oh but I make the match
listen dudes will come on anything don't
mean you was great
just because you know how to make a dude
do it when you use your hands or your
mouth doesn't mean you don't have to
make all guys do it you don't have that
super but you've convinced yourself
because you've had some good feedback
that don't make you amazing
yeah no I'm just making you amazing
maybe someone lied to you maybe you're
good though maybe you're good or
whatever nope I got nothing else all
right listen I just wanted to talk about
this because like it's just pet peeves
of mine good subject I just pet peace on
mine I'm nerves because I'm like y'all
don't know what you're doing no
here's the thing I didn't know what I
was doing for which is fine I was maybe
26 and that's what I discovered because
I had one partner who blew me out the
[__] water yeah she blew me at the
bottom
Hey listen if the guy's watching know
I'll talk about y'all ever had one of
them level two Buster nuts you know what
I mean them tsunami alerts where you
gotta hold on to the reals cause you
like yo bro am I coming or am I peeing
because that [__] is a flood okay
they actually had my whole leg twitching
this [__]
and everything she was doing from
physical touch to foreplay to like
taking her time I'm like yo this is all
Jasmine Whole New World right so
it made me realize oh everything I know
before this was so one-dimensional
there's people who approach this from
every [__] angle yeah and then she
opened my eyes to being able to be
physically intimate in a much more
deeper way and so all this to say it's
okay to not know it's okay to be like
you know what I got a lot to learn and
you know I've enjoyed the experience
I've had up until now but I don't think
I'm easy it's okay to be humble about
this whole [__] but everybody want to
act like they topped up